and mourinho's making his second start
this year he has never beaten the
oakland age but he pitched well enough
to win in his start in oakland five
innings just one run allowed that was
one of the games of the doubleheader
that the twins were shut out in both
games
and so he's hoping for a similar
not effort the effort's always there but
a similar performance in terms of
limiting this a's lineup
fastball for strike three cannon very
quickly disposed of one away
boy i love that about
95 miles an hour it's right there
see if you can hit it canada couldn't do
it
called third strike laureano thought he
had a walk rios burns the outside corner
he got close enough to it anyway so
here's olson he'll try to knock in seth
brown
and it was a fast ball and it's driven
to right center field and deep and that
baby's gone
so the a's played long ball last night
they open up
today
by playing long ball again their fifth
home run in this series pack your bag
zoli
all aboard next stop
pound town
taking on the southpaw swerve and cola
irvine making his eighth turn of the
season and has quickly become one of the
most consistent starters really
across baseball
hit hard to center field forward the
bullpen
and it bounces over the wall
and donaldson will go to second with a
double
and garlic slapping his right thigh and
that's kind of how
the things have gone for the twins if
that hits the top of the fence garlic
scores
hayes have the infield back
for nelson cruz
that'll score a run
cruz putting it in play garlic scores
donald's into third base and it's two to
one
and as a matter of fact
short of
nelson hitting a home run or a double
bambi that's a great event
and the oh wanna swing the weak round
ball wide of first who's going to play
at ceno will has to tag out kemp and
does
for the out so barrios went to the bag
cino went for the ball
with some
communication there late and miguel took
charge and tagged out kemp going by
that's true you're right you like have
your own
robotic camera don't don't know that i
deserve it very appreciate sure you do
garcia lines one off the glove of
polanco
picks it up
but it's going to be a base hit
right hand batter against the right hand
pitcher it's the first pitch and it's a
breaking ball it's laced into left field
that's the base it lands on a balance in
front of ref snyder and that will bring
home canna and the a's lead it three to
one
loriano jumping on the first offering
from barrios and he gets his 17th rbi
and the a's add on in the third
biscotti then pinder and kemp as we
start the fourth inning with the
camouflage hats some wearing camouflage
shoes and others there's a swing and a
liner toward the left field corner it is
down and it is by rep snyder has to take
the camera off the wall steven hustling
to second and he will slide in with a
double
it's his fourth of the year as he turns
on barrios
and he's in scoring position to start
the fourth inning for oakland kepler
cruz garber rosario and sono to have 30
home runs here comes the 1-2 pitch
fastball strike on the outside corner
freezes to know he is gone a-looking
and a solid four innings for cole ervin
as we go to the fifth it is 3-1 oakland
so it's a 3-1 a's lead over the twins
and canna hits one very high
very deep and that baby is gone
second deck four to one a's
the green and gold continue to make
deposits into the upper deck at target
field here
markana lean back
can i get a bat flip
so cannon's seventh home run of the year
see canada talking about
what my back was like this the ball went
so far i couldn't see it
and how about that play that is a good
play all around by olson and cole irvin
you laugh you say it's a do or die play
it is
well it is
the degree of difficulty is something
that i'll probably spend the next 15
minutes wrapping my head around because
olsen's got a range to his right
backhand
while on the move he's got to turn his
body like you see and then at some point
in time he has to make a decision am i
going to try to lead cole irvine do i
put enough on it just to
get it to him where he's at and coal
the athletic move in his own right
having to reach back across his body the
01 to garlic is swung on and driven to
left canada going over he's there diving
and sprawling and rolls over and hangs
on with a backhanded play
the athletics flashing the leather in
the bottom of the fifth it's a one two
three inning and after five the a's lead
the twins four to one nicole urban's
been good again becoming quite a story
for the athletics big left-hander
back to irvine joey
but he gets a lot of outs with that
change up doesn't he
it's a money maker here's the pitch now
and a change up rolled over ground ball
to short pinder goes to camp he goes to
first and the a's get a six four three
double play and that's it for the twins
in the bottom of the sixth and after six
still four to one athletic
i fly right field and deep
garlic underneath it
to end the inning seven innings his
longest outing of the year but barrios
comes off the mound trailing four to one
they are six and twelve at home
driven to the gap right center field
slicing away from l'oreal and he won't
get there
palanco to second he'll hold up there
with a double and the twins have
something started at least here in the
seventh
used to seeing laureato make catches
like that that time he
wasn't able to pull it off
one-two pitch he hits it hard hinders
got it throws to third did they get him
no
pinder grabbed it in the air
and then alertly fired to third to see
just how far
polanco had came off the bag
and it runs inside with a fastball and
simmons takes the walk and the bases are
loaded
bob melvin pops out of the dugout and he
has made the call
to the bullpen so you samara pedit is
coming in and the 1-0 pitch to arise and
a fastball is popped up third base side
foul ground toward the shadows goes
chapman reaches on the tarp and he pulls
it back
unbelievable play by matt chapman
he sticks the glove on the backhand
reaches out and comes with the baseball
and denies minnesota in the seventh
platinum glover indeed
as chapman lunges at the last moment
over the tarp and makes a tremendous
catch
see the right fielder piscottis about
three steps in front of the warning
track loop to right hand over the reach
of kemp
cruz around third he'll score ref
schneider drives in a run and it's four
to two here's how miguelsa
world has changed they brought in a
left-hander
to face him
a high fly to right field back is
piscotty at the wall
it's gone
so delivers and the twins take the lead
miguel
goes up all
a get off my back go ahead three-run
homer to right and the twins take a 5-4
lead
and target field he reps for the first
time
in nearly two years
the tying run is in scoring position
on the ground
donaldson has it
that wasn't so hard was it
big big win for the twins for so many
reasons